Donald Trump's press secretary is gone and
he has hired a new one.
Now, you might be confused by this because
you might have had no idea of who is now former
press secretary was Stephanie Grisham because
she never held an actual press briefing.
The last press briefing was March 11, not
of this year of 2019.
It's been about 13 months.
And now here's the even more insane part.
The person that Donald Trump has selected
to be his new press secretary is the same
person I mentioned to you on Monday as one
of the biggest disseminators of unconscionable
Corona virus propaganda, disinformation.
Her name is Kailee McKenney.
McKenny is a religious extremist, anti-abortion
nut case who has dozens of embarrassing public
statements memorialized on the Internet.
Statements that really should be career ending,
not career bolstering.
But she is sycophantic league pro Trump, which
makes her a perfect candidate to be Donald
Trump's press secretary.
Reminder.
Here is Kaylie's comment, which I played for
you earlier this week, where she argues that
because Trump is America first, we will never
have something like Corona virus in the United
States.
Looking at the coronavirus and the president
saying, now, look, we're we're not gonna take
people in from China right now.
I mean, isn't it just a matter of protecting
our national security really being at stake
and he's sort of the last line of defense?
Well, first I and say absolutely.
This president will always put America first.
He will always protect American citizens.
We will not see diseases like the coronavirus
come here.
We will not see terrorism come here.
Isn't that refreshing when contrasting it
with the awful presidency of President Obama?
caney McInerney, thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
Of course, that ship has long sailed.
We have almost three times as many cases confirmed
as any other country on this planet.
And it is an absolute embarrassment.
But in the bizarro backwards universe where
Donald Trump is president, that sort of unhinged,
irrational support of Trump gets you a job
in the normal world.
If things were fair and life is not fair.
Someone who says something as laughably ridiculous
as what Kaley McInerny said there, that would
get you fired.
It would destroy your career.
It would make it so you have trouble getting
a job in the era of Trump.
You get a promotion.
And we are in a world where ignorance is rewarded.
As long as the ignorance is complimentary
to the president of the United States, we
are in a world where being wrong is rewarded
as long as you stood in line and supported
the president.
Now it's important to mention Kaley McKenny
is a creation of the corporate media.
She worked as the producer of Mike Huckabee's
Fox News show Back in the Day, started appearing
on CNN regularly to defend Donald Trump.
That got her on Trump's radar regularly appeared
on all sorts of corporate media networks.
And this is how Trump hires people.
He picks people he likes on TV who will irrationally
defend him no matter what it is that he does.
And being a young woman doesn't help when
Donald Trump is doing the hiring based on
your physical appearance, appearance and the
things you say about him on television.
Now, a few of Kaylie's career highlights include
Obama birtherism, defending Donald Trump's
performance in that Access Hollywood grab
him by the you know what tape and defending
any crazy notion that Donald Trump has ever
floated perfect fit for a Trump staffer.
When we say someone worships Trump, it's usually
an exaggeration.
But here it actually seems like worship describes
her presence on television.
Precisely.
And just wait for her press briefings if they
ever happen.
Right.
I mean, they may not.
Stephanie Grisham, Trump's last press secretary,
never did a press briefing.
So Trump continuing to hire the best people,
as he likes to say.
And of course, the reality is very much the
opposite.
Let me remind you that tomorrow, tomorrow,
tomorrow, tomorrow, April 9, Thursday, we
are doing a one day membership bomb.
We lost three hundred and eighty nine members
in March because of the virus.
People tightening their belts.
I get it.
We're down a few dozen members in April because
of the virus.
I get it.
I don't want your last dollar, but if you
can afford a membership at a grotesquely,
disgustingly discounted rate, we're sending
out a membership discount code tomorrow, April
9, at 2:00 p.m. Eastern.
All you have.
Due to be notified is get on my mailing list
at David Pakman dot com top right of the Web
site, it says sign up for the newsletter.
You type in your e-mail address tomorrow at
2:00 p.m.
You will get that e-mail.
I hope you will participate.
We want to set a single day record for new
memberships.
And of course, I want to hear from you about
your thoughts on Donald Trump's press secretary
selection, Kaley McKenney.
Let me know what you think.